all right
let's do this I'm getting notes of uh
dried Robin's blood old dirty cashews
and just a hint of a robot's bath water
poison
oh I made a mistake
I made a mistake
had not of this watered down baby
formula not even close not even close
Marvin clones
Glenn Close Leslie you don't have to do
this go to bed Jimmy
why I can't feel my face
my face is numb
what is it
my parents make me so mad sometimes just
like the time they couldn't decide who
gets the dog so they just dropped off
the local synagogue I was like
oh say what
hold on Ron hold that thought just for a
sec
hey honey hey uh it's your me it's wife
uh nope I have very big news for you oh
my teeth are blue
berries are you having a stroke I was
just saying Iran that my dog's Jewish
oh phone water Ben
hello
oh hello hi
Leslie it's dead hello
you know Leslie sounded weird I don't
want to wait for Tom I want to walk home
I'll join you I'm always game for a
brisk walk also if I leave you alone I'm
pretty sure you'll die
home is that way
watch out for that fence this comes from
your mother's butt hello sir we're sober
we would like to get tattoos in our
bodies because we love each other
tattoos this is a pawn shop
but yeah sure I can do that
[Applause]
luxury right here
come here
everybody pants now pants pants pants
pants pants she's had enough call it off
that's not how it works she's out wait
I'm subbing in April no that stuff will
melt the shell off a garden snail
whatever I'm Puerto Rican I can handle
it
oh my God
okay this ends now you know in the
movies when the cops show up and find
lipstick on a wine glass next to a dead
body
this is that wine
do you think I have been around the
world
It's Been Everywhere darling I'm a very
wealthy woman my husband kept me in the
finest clothes from Bergdorf Goodman
Museum
I didn't kill anybody and I didn't burn
down the middle either my sister did but
now she's been eaten by wolves
nothing to see here
hey yeah hmm
son there's no wrong way to consume
alcohol
[Music]
here's your Bud Light I ordered a beer
that is a beer and here's your Nimbus
martini
and I go ahead and chisel your
aromosphere please
this is the wrong way to consume alcohol
whoa that's a pretty stiff Cloud word of
the scotch right here hold out your
hands please
what's happening oh this is a sort of
play on Scotch it's a whiskey infused
lotion can I ask if this entire
establishment is a practical joke of
some kind if you don't like the scotch
they have a vodka that's served in the
form of a flashlight
I can't take it anymore okay I'm
breaking you up you guys are done fine
with me fine
oh April I'm drunk you made me drunk you
made me drunk and you nope nope give it
a rest I need it okay
fine let's get you to bed you know why
why fighting anyway it's so stupid I
hate Anne because of the stupid reason
and I hate Tom for this stupid reason
s
yeah Mom
you're going back to the farm
and you you're going back to Hell fine I
got what I came for anyway I found your
underground safe I stole half your gold
that's decoy gold
you think I'd leave my gold in a lock
safe buried underground where anyone
could find it you don't know me at all
yes I do I knew you the minute you were
born I intend to be there the minute you
die
Ron your family's weird can I ask you a
question are we the cutest couple you've
ever seen nope okay you want the long
needle or the short needle doesn't
matter can't find a shorten it a long
needle it is I am a big idea I want a
portrait of Eleanor Roosevelt Tastefully
done and then she has a very classy
tattoo of Pat Benatar in her arm and
that's very subtle no scratch that
scratch all that just right Ben you have
anything to numb the pain sure take a
scoop at a peel bucket
okay you said you wanted Mouse Queen no
stop stop it stop everything that you're
doing stop it and here and wants a
tattoo
25 infants today only one as deemed
himself worthy of a sommelier
certificate oh my God are you sure no
way oh my God thank you thank you so
much everyone I think we can agree that
all wine tastes the same and if you
spend more than five dollars on wine you
are very stupid security I just want to
thank all the people that got me here
Norbit uh Pluto Nash all the clumps you
don't even know what they're gonna even
say what they gonna do she asked me the
whole thing and I didn't even do it once
I'm like an elephant okay if I walk into
a room it's like okay he's in there
Baba Boy
turn this music down
[Music]
today
I'm assuming I'm very angry about but
other on he's not helping me with it can
you help I can tell by the Indigo on
your chick lips that you've been
drinking blueberry wine
that's a good start the wall of Pope
called it matapiqua
they believed it had mystical Powers
Yeah it also tastes like jelly so what's
got your goat there friend my parents
they had this lake house and they sold
it without telling me and so I was like
why you know it was like God you guys
oh you're hanging on to that anger for
dear life compadre
let's role play oh yeah
you're surrendering to the Earth Mother
stare into the fire and picture your
spirit animal I don't know what my
spirit animal is because it doesn't
exist because that's nonsense because
you're an adult
baby snow
out that's right
Leslie
I'm here
we have to go hire a new PR director for
the health department oh my God I'm so
hungover
I've never been this hungover I feel
great I ran 5K this morning
really no I threw up in the shower